alrighty so now that we know how to
submit scores to leaderboards let's go
through the process of removing these
hard-coded strings I'm going to do
something a little different than the
achievement manager you'll remember in
the achievement manager we created a new
enum for each of the achievements now I
could do the same thing for our leader
boards but the thing is where we
basically already have any num set up
for this if you look in our enemies H
file we have this difficulty level 1 and
since our leader boards correspond
exactly to difficulty levels I'm just
going to go ahead and reuse this I'm
going to do so let's see i'm going to
set this to 0 just to kind of ensure
that yes easy really is going to
correspond to 0 and then in our
leaderboard manager i'm going to create
a new method called submit score for
difficulty level and that's right I
gotta go up here and import my Keenum's
difficulty level well xcode why are you
giving me there we go all right now to
implement this I do still need to create
the array of static strings that lets me
know what leaderboard corresponds to you
know each difficulty level so I'm going
to do our static and a string Const
leaderboard IDs and that will equal and
now I got to go to my developer console
and make sure I copy and paste these so
let's bring that up there you go and
copy this one let's copy this one I
think these are really all the same
except for the last letter here but just
in case I always like copying and
pasting there we go and can do this and
we convey it a little in a string for
our leaderboard ID and that equals our
leaderboard IDs level and you know
actually you know what I'm just going to
combine these two methods into one so
there we go we get our leaderboard ID by
looking at our leaderboard IDs array and
then basically I'm just going to combine
this with the rest of the submit score
for leaderboard ID method now I
basically just need to go back to my dot
H file and delete this method because we
no longer want to use it and we're
pretty good so now I can go back to my
game model class and replace this method
where I'm submitting a score to a
hard-coded leaderboard string to just
leaderboard manager submit score num
guesses for difficulty level and 0 at
this point I realized you know what I'm
not actually storing the difficulty
level anywhere in this class well this
is something we can fix with a simple
property or
variable let me just go up here and add
it as a property by the way I often go
back and forth about whether i should be
storing these these private variables as
you know little little ants here or as
actual properties in the class extension
I go back and forth I'm not quite sure
if one way is really considered more
proper than the other but I'm just going
to go ahead and do it here I'm going to
create a little int that is going to
store our difficulty level so there we
go I do know however that since I've
kind of created most of these others as
properties I don't know why I'm then
referring to them using their private
variable names with this underscore game
X underscore secret number I should
probably be using some self dot notation
here sorry about that but in any case I
guess I'll be consistently incorrect
here and we'll store our difficulty
level has the level that gets passed in
and now this has been recorded I can now
go back to the bottom here and for
difficulty level I can now change that
to difficulty level property or and
there you go let's run this now and
we'll see that
whoa hey look at that three guesses I
got a better score than before and by
the way you will notice as I mentioned
before in the score report that gets
returned the high score for player today
all those bullion's are are true and the
actual highscore objects are no remember
those only get returned if you did not
get a new high score for today or for
the week or all time and now it's even
better is without without any extra work
of my part I can now go ahead and play a
medium difficulty game whoo boy I'm
guess I should have made a more fun game
to play all right there we go and now
I've submitted a high score to the
medium leaderboard as well so let's go
back check our leader boards here's our
medium leaderboard and there I am with
score of 10 I could likewise do the same
for the Hard difficulty level but I
really don't want to play a game where I
guess a number between one and ten
thousand so I will leave that as an
exercise to the viewer so we're almost
done here the only other refinement I
want to make is I found it sort of
awkward they had to go back here this
main screen to view the leaderboards for
the game I was just playing gee wouldn't
it be nice if in the middle of playing
my easy game I could see the current
high scores and so we can do that pretty
easily as well and we'll tackle that
final step in the next lesson so I'll
see you soon
baba
haha